l'effet que news qui signifie fausses
informations sont entrés dans notre
langage courant pour lutter contre la
désinformation une conférence était
organisée à la médiathèque du canal sur
le thème du climat
on n'a pas un journal télé sans des
chiffres qui sont produits ou qui sont
contestés par la suite
donc ça nous a semblé intéressant pour
une médiathèque de traiter ces sujets là
pierre hippolyte senlis a animé cette
conférence et fait partie de
l'association fait coffre première
association de journalistes à s'engager
contre la désinformation de masse avec
trente journalistes ils se sont
regroupés suite aux attentats de charlie
hebdo
là on avait un peu tout les toutes les
théories
complotistes ou de désinformation un peu
con qui sont sortis donc ça est un peu
violent et là on sait on s'est dit
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire la défiance
médiatique a été abordé avec les 50
participants avec tchernobyl lincendie
l'hubris hull et de rouen ils ont
aiguisé leur esprit critique
ils sont revenus également sur greta
tanberg la lanceuse d'alert le
journaliste à alerter le public sur
l'importance de vérifier les sources
un premier pas pour lutter contre la
désinformation ce qui m'a vraiment
intéressé et que je ne connaissais pas
c'est la recherche inverse survol d'une
information on a une photo aux pics
google en inverse et nous dit cette
photo elle date de talent époque se
rapprocher de l'essentiel c'est le
message du journaliste lors de cette
conférence
la prochaine aura lieu le jeudi 7
janvier à 19 heures à la médiathèque du
canal